can i talk to you guys about something
actually teddy this is not a good time
we're still having a pretty big fight
well i think what i'm about to say
myself things
amy i'm still in love with you what what
what oh
i skipped this cup scoop this is super
uncomfortable
jazz
okay okay everybody just calm down and
take a deep breath
what the hell is going on man yeah what
the hell is going on you got a
girlfriend i know and she's fine
thanks sorry i was really planning on
you being in the cab during this okay
that wouldn't make it better maybe i'm
just i'm not over you yet and i would
have never said anything because i
thought you and jake were happy but
after seeing you at jazz brunch i think
i might have been wrong don't read into
that that was a freak argument we are
very happy amy we have all the same
interests we have so much chemistry when
we're together it's like no matter where
we are in san diego feel compelled to
tell you that san diego's terrible to
lay it all in the line
amy santiago
will you marry me what okay really could
you stay in the cab i'm sorry i'll be
right there i promise or maybe i won't
what's your answer teddy i don't want to
be with you but you want to be with him
you guys have nothing in common oh yeah
tell that to william atherton the man we
both considered to be the second best
die-hard villain oh she meant it and
also yes we are different people but i
love that about us i love that jake's a
little messy and that he cares so much
about his dumb sneakers and he doesn't
get stressed out about calendars or
flossing my teeth no the non-flossing is
crazy copy that and i love you i'm just
so confused your fight was like
something out of a movie
teddy i have to tell you the truth no
amy is dying she has one month to live
marrying her would be a waste of time
jake and i were only pretending to fight
so that we could destroy your phone
while we were on the stakeout and you
were in the bathroom we said you were
the most boring man in america and your
phone recorded it i'm sorry we didn't
want you to get mad at us and fail the
precinct wow
you guys are the worst well you just
proposed in front of your girlfriend so
potato potato amy i loved you
all right i'm ready to go rachel should
we hit up the tenement museum no we
called the bomb squad and got everyone
out of the building we should leave who
would do something like this well i
clearly have an arch nemesis
finally must be someone i put away who's
hell-bent on revenge he's probably gonna
make me choose between saving the city
and saving the woman i love little does
he know i can save both
how are you so calm right now someone is
trying to blow us up i'm calm because
there's not really a bomb i mean if
you're trying to kill someone you don't
call and give them a heads up so they're
just trying to scare us yeah but it
doesn't matter the bomb squad's on their
way they'll do a quick sweep find
nothing and split and this will just
become a funny story we work into our
vows amy there was a bomb at this
wedding you butt you butt is the bomb
please don't say that during the
ceremony is it that you don't like
wordplay or you don't want me to talk
about your butt at all because one of
those notes is really gonna pull through
how did this guy even find out about the
wedding
the stupid engagement announcement
charles put in the paper it had the time
and location of the ceremony amy be very
careful about throwing around
accusations like that because if you're
trying to say i somehow ruined jake's
wedding then i'm gonna kill myself
so tread lightly okay just take it easy
charles nothing is ruined
see the bomb squad is already here and
they brought a robot this is exactly how
i imagined my wedding would be when i
was a kid well well well
amy santiago amy look your ex-boyfriend
is here on our wedding day why this is
my crew yeah you called me boring so i
leveled up my cool and now i run the
bomb squad i also started traveling i
went to belgium they have the best
spaghetti teddy let's get everything out
on the table here last time we saw you
you kind of proposed to amy so you're
not still in love with her right no i
definitely am my therapist told me to
stop trying to get over it oh weird you
wouldn't hide it even for your own pride
but seriously don't worry i'm a cop i
have a job to do and i'm gonna do it
professionally that's great i'm happy to
hear that meaning i will be doing a
super thorough sweeping of the building
it's gonna take hours so you should
probably just cancel the wedding anyway
congrats you two congrats on the bomb
squad charles let's go check on teddy
i'm sure he's made a ton of progress
nope i haven't even gone in yet still
putting on the bomb suit yeah my job is
super dangerous but i like living life
on the edge just kind of sexy if you
think about it there's no bomb if they
wanted us dead they wouldn't have called
first not always the bomber who calls
maybe had a young daughter found a key
to a secret room came across some
blueprints felt guilty and wanted to
save your life seems unlikely well amy
in this life it's sometimes the
unlikeliest outcomes it feels like
you're winding up to propose again here
i was good catching amy would you no
bill did it all right well this is gonna
take a while so you have time to
reconsider
off to do my super dangerous job
teddy and i are the only ones left i'm
gonna win this no matter how much he
talks about light rail systems ooh you
should ride the one in akron by the way
very little noise oh my god enough about
light rails let's talk trams amusement
parks
more cities adopted the music park
method oh put your hands on my ears
me i'm on the stroller
oh i see what i did wrong it's okay come
on let's get you home excuse me
amy you can have the stroller for the
right price okay how much
amy santiago will you marry me
you